- My name's Claudia, and I am currently
a freshman at MIT.
I'm from South Florida, and
now my journey continues here.
(uplifting music)
My family is from the Azores islands,
which are in the middle of the Atlantic.
Just knowing that where
my family comes from
and the lack of education,
they've built me up
with such important
skills of interpersonal
communication, team building, leadership
and now it's just my turn to take
this and put it in an academic context.
(uplifting music)
Being a first-generation
high school graduate,
first-generation college student,
I didn't really have that background
of really good testing
skills or just the role
models around me to really show
me how to do things academically.
Getting the academic support
had to come from somewhere,
and Khan Academy being online, being free
and available, having SAT prep,
even pairing up with the College Board,
I was able to get accurate
very, very closely-related
questions, so when I was on the test,
nothing was a surprise.
(uplifting music)
So whenever it's free,
it's open, it's fair.
And I have that fire in my stomach
that I know that this
is where I want to be,
this is what I want to do.
I have so many opinions and so many things
I find wrong with the
world, and I really know
that this is a place where I can grow,
learn, and gain even more skills
to be able to do just that.
(inspiring music)